how to go from small talk to deep
conversation
i'm chad and let's get started
[Music]
so through uh my work i've gotten to
facilitate
thousands of conversations with hundreds
of thousands of people
about all sorts of topics and
in that work i've learned a couple
really key lessons
that have helped me create more
conversations that matter and so in this
video
i'm going to unpack and start with
sharing a story about amanda
student in a program that i was
facilitating training that i was
facilitating at san jose state
university
two days ago actually and i'm gonna
share
the relearning or aha that i had
in relation to how do you take
conversations from small talk which very
few people like
to real talk to deeper conversation
in a comfortable natural way and so in
this video
i'm going to share this main paradigm
that i learned but first amanda so i'm
facilitating this program
and amanda unmuted it was virtual and a
man unmuted and shared something about
herself
and i realized she only spoke for about
five seconds but in that five seconds i
asked the rest of the group i asked
amanda are you okay being put on the
spot for a minute
and i asked our the rest of the group
what did we just learn about amanda and
even though she only spoke for five
seconds
we were able to come up with more than
five things that we learned
about amanda and yet most people in that
setting the conversation would have just
fell flat
and yet in my mind one of the
most powerful tools to go from small
talk to real talk or small talk to
deeper conversation
is to follow that curiosity but in a
very specific direction which i'll
explain in a moment
because a big part of my job is inviting
people to stretch outside of their
comfort zone i believe that every year
i need to do at least one big thing that
stretches me outside of my own comfort
zone and so
last year i was on a 10-day kayak
camping retreat in the middle of the
woods no self-service for
over a week in total wilderness
paddling from site to site where we were
camping and there was a lot of alone
time there was a lot of time to think
and in aha showed up for me
which is um this graph that we're gonna
put up right here
so from a spectrum of small talk over
here
over to real talk over here you're
watching this video because you want to
be on this side of the graph
now to add one dimension to this i would
say the most powerful tool
to move from one place to the other is
curiosity and so we draw
another line coming down from a level of
high curiosity
to a level of low curiosity the tool
that i would love for you to employ is
follow your vertical curiosity and what
i mean by that is
go up with your curiosity as opposed to
what most of us do
is horizontal curiosity shopping so we
kind of like bounce from topic to topic
to topic
as opposed to going really deep and
intentional with one thought by
listening very deeply
and continuing to be curious about that
element kind of circling down that
vertical curiosity
is the easiest tool that you can just
choose to do
to go to goo to go from
small talk to real talk now let me be
really clear for me the definition as
far as small talk
has nothing to do with the topic of
conversation so typically when we think
about small talk we think about the
weather
or where you're from or what do you do i
would say that small talk has everything
to do with the process and the way that
you're having the conversation
two meteorologists talking about the
weather might not be small talk it might
be a really good conversation
and so we can't eliminate or judge
whether a topic is worthy of being
called deeper conversation
just by the topic of conversation and so
the process
really is following that makes real
conversation happen
is following your genuine curiosity
vertically
not horizontally and also listening
curiosity
and great questions are worthless
without these two appendages on the side
of our head
that allow us to retain information
understand it
and potentially spit it back because
when we listen
really well we can get curious about
many more things and so in particular
going back to who we'll call amanda from
san jose state university
the piece that she shared she asked
everybody to go grab an
object that had some meaning to them and
she brought back this little tiny frame
with a constellation in it
and she just shared i'm not really into
zodiac signs but i'm a cancer
and she said like maybe one other phrase
and that was it there was no other
context
and yet when i asked the group what did
you learn from amanda
they were able to come up with five or
more things right she's kind into zodiac
but not really but knows enough to be
dangerous
she's a cancer she's a comfortable
enough to share
in front of the group right so now we
start to travel into things that she
didn't
say verbatim but were present in the
actual group and so there's some
massive value in thing in realizing that
if you listen really intentionally
what you're curious about will change
because what you hear will actually
fundamentally be different i've unpacked
this in a couple
other videos about how to start
conversations with new people
that you can check out right here but
one of my
by far my favorite features of
conversation is this idea that um
dialogue is exponential conversation and
connection is exponential and here's
exactly what i mean by that
so if i learn about this plant
right if i learn that it used to grow
in a greenhouse 15 minutes away
if i if that's all i learned about this
plant right i can ask
who works at that greenhouse who started
that greenhouse what's the story behind
it what does the owner care about
right we could go on for this video
could be unnecessarily long
coming up with questions about the story
of just a plan
human beings are way more complex and so
when you
when somebody speaks for 10 seconds
almost
certainly you can learn at least three
things from them
and then if you ask a question about any
of these three things
you'll learn three more things and then
you ask a question about
any of those and you've got three more
topics and so you can see how
conversation is exponential
and yet typically i think this is really
important because with people
that we're close to in our personal
lives but also especially colleagues in
our work lives
we follow like one curiosity path a
little bit we go horizontal curiosity
we kind of like learn all the facts
about somebody right here
but we never get past like five layers
deep
of curiosity and so you're watching this
video because you want to go from small
talk to deeper conversation
this is the way to do it break past that
barrier because usually we go about
three layers deep
in curiosity and then we put somebody in
a box and they stay in that box and our
curiosity dies and
you know just before recording actually
i was leading a workshop
for rutgers university and somebody
asked a question
about um when you work with colleagues
for ten plus years you feel like you
know everything
about them even though realistically you
only know
two percent of their uh world and yet
you put them in a box you don't if you
work somebody for 10 years
it was probably in the first year that
they landed in the box
it was either like he's the funny guy
he's always a jokester
he's the curmudgeon who's always cranky
and has nothing positive to say in a
meeting right we put people in these
boxes
and that limits or puts a ceiling on our
curiosity
and prevents that vertical curiosity
from piercing through
and i would say to take a personal note
from this when um
and will my co-founder and partner
really taught me this
when my curiosity is uh
not present with kate my wife our
relationship
is dead right when i am not curious
about who kate is there is no
progression there's no relationship
uh moving forward in that sense the
coolest part though is that curiosity is
a choice
it's a choice and it's also kind of like
a muscle the more you use it the more
uh easy it is to use the more curious
you are
the more easy it is to be curious
there's this like awesome cyclical
effect
but you're watching this video to go
from small talk to deeper conversation
and so really all you have to do
is be curious three times today and then
three times
tomorrow and the more days you go on
being curious following that curiosity
with questions
the deeper conversations you'll find
yourself having and if you're asking
rather than
random curiosities from your brain if
you're asking about what somebody has
just shared with you from what you've
listened
the conversation will very quickly move
from small talk
to real talk if you enjoyed this video
uh
it turns out that my job is helping
people create conversations that matter
well and i wrote a book about it it's
called ask powerful questions create
conversations that matter there's a link
below
with a free excerpt from it there's also
this thing called
amazon i've heard of it recently that
actually carries books believe it or not
they sell them on the internet it's
amazing
um awesome hand on cyberspace with you
have an awesome
day